>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> It's my honor and pleasure
today to introduce our next author,
one of the world's best known
and most successful writers who's
earned a tremendous reputation
for his writing especially
in the area of crime novels.
But before I do that,
we need to attend
to a few housekeeping details.
First, we want to thank the
cochairman of the festival,
David Rubenstein and the many
National Book Festival sponsors
who have made this year's
event possible and those
who supported us for
the last 17 years.
You too can support the
National Book Festival
with the gift of a donation.
We welcome your help in making
the festival possible next year
and every year, and it would not
be possible to have this even event
without sponsors like you.
A question and answer period
will follow the presentation,
so save your questions for then
and also be aware that anyone
who does ask a question will be
recorded for what will become part
of the library's collection.
So, please silence your mobile
phones and now for our closer.
David Baldacci is the bestselling
author of more than 30 novels
which are print to the tune of over
a 110 million copies worldwide.
Several of his books
have been turned
into motion pictures and television.
David is a good friend of
the Library of Congress
and has played a role in
previous National Book Festivals.
And this year, he's playing
in a festival doubleheader.
Earlier today at the Teen Stage
he talked about his latest book
for young adults which entitled,
"The Width of the World."
And now we welcome back here
to the Main Stage to talk
about another of his new books.
Needless to say, David's
work is well-represented
in the library's collection.
Checking our online catalog this
morning, I saw that 81 examples
of his works are represented;
included all of his printed works,
but also related audiobooks
and one major motion picture.
Neatly enough, his books in our
collection run from A to Z. That is,
from "Absolute Power" to "Zero
Day" with all the rest in between,
including his latest book
"The Fix", which features one
of his most unique protagonists
FBI Agent, Amos Decker,
the man who is unable
to forget anything.
As is well-known by David's
fans who live and work in
and around the District of
Columbia, one of the great pleasures
of his books is the direct way
he works the local landscape
and institutions into his stories.
For example, his newest book started
out just a short distance from here
in front of the FBI Building.
And another example, which is
even closer to home for me,
is the use of the Library of
Congress as a main setting
for his 2009 novel,
"The Collectors."
What's more, one of the
books victims is the chief
of our rare book and special
collections [inaudible].
So, by the way, in real
life he's a great guy
and a special colleague of mine.
I just have one more point
before calling David up here.
While I'm certainly no infallible
memory man like Amos Decker,
I always remember the tremendous
efficacy for literacy that David
and his wife Michelle have
provided through the establishment
of their nonprofit Wish
You Well Foundation.
The foundation supports adult and
family literacy across the country
by fostering and promoting literacy
and other educational programs.
So, please join me in welcoming
David Baldacci, a great writer,
a good friend of the library,
and a great humanitarian.
[ Applause ]
>> David Baldacci: I was marveled
by how many people were here.
If it would have been me, I would
have already left, 6:30 on Saturday,
where is the why, you know so.
I appreciate you for hanging
around for the closing act.
It's great.
I spoke earlier on the Teen Stage
and seeing all these young
readers here is just, oh my gosh,
it's so energizing for me.
It's such great news
and I just loved it.
It's great to be back.
I think this is probably
my 6th or 7th visit
to the National Book Festival.
I think at some point I told
them to stop inviting me,
but I'm kind of the local guy right
across the river in Virginia, so.
Whenever I go to places that have
festivals, I always make this remark
which I think is a good one,
"Never take them for granted."
Because once you start
taking great things like this
for granted, they tend to go away.
You know? So, always come, encourage
your friends and family to come.
Bring new people in.
They'll have a great time.
I signed for about an hour
today and everybody who came
through had a smile on their face.
They were just happy about
being here surrounded by people
who are book lovers as well,
so always support the
National Book Festival.
It's a great thing.
You know, the bestseller's life
when I'm out on tour I get a lot
of questions from people "What is
like to be you know this
worldwide bestselling novelist?"
And I know the way they ask
question they want me to give like,
you know, a Kardashian answer.
My life is not like the
Kardashians trust me.
Even when I go to a cool event and
I come home and tell my mother,
my wife about it, and she
stops me halfway through
and she goes "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, it's trash night.
Get on it."
People always ask, you know,
"all of your books you always
have strong independent women.
Why is that?"
I said, "I sleep with one."
So, an answer to that
question "What is
like to be a bestselling
novelist", I tell the people a story
about my kids when they were little.
My kids are grown now, but when they
were little like I took my daughter,
she was around 5 or 6 to a book
signing that I was going to do
for the first time; took her with
me at this great little bookstore.
We walked in, the lady who owned
it came over and greeted us
and asked my daughter, you know,
"Do you know why all
these people are here?"
And my daughter said,
"Yes, yes I do know."
"Why are they here?"
"They want my dad to
sign their book."
"And why do they want your
dad to sign their book?"
"Because my dad has the
nicest handwriting."
[Brief laughter].
My son is my little entrepreneur,
you know, he's in his 20s now,
but when he was like 3,I
took him to a bookstore just
to go buy some books and he
walked into the bookstore
and he saw all the people reading
all the books on the shelf,
his eyes got huge and all of
a sudden he started running
across the bookstore screaming
at the top of his lungs,
"My daddy will sign any book
you've got for 2 dollars."
[ Laughter ]
So, that's what it's like to
be a bestselling novelist.
You'll be pleased to know, because
I love the National Book Festival,
in my earlier signing I
waived my 2 dollar fee
and I signed all the books for free.
Amos Decker, it's interesting
when I decided to create a series
around him, I thought okay,
I want to do a new series.
I wonder what kind of a
character I should create?
Okay, I'll create a guy
who has no social skills,
rubs everybody the wrong way.
He's sort of like this
obese, big you know,
flabby guy who can't
get along with anyone.
He'll be very popular I'm sure
and he has been incredibly popular
and I think it's because he's
unlike any character I've ever
created before.
And I've been interested in
the brain for a longtime,
obviously it's what makes us us.
And when something happens to the
brain, you know, you read a lot
about football these days with
TBIs and CTE and all that.
The brain is a unique, you know,
ability to sort of heal itself
in some ways, so if one part of
it is damaged it rewires itself;
rewires itself around the damaged
part and tries to keep going
as much as it possibly can.
So, I thought I'm going to
create a character who has,
is going to have a TBI and
he's going to come out of it
with perfect recall, perfect memory,
hyperthymesia which
is a real condition.
You're either born with it or
you can get it through a TBI.
And let's see how that
goes with him.
And when most people, when
I went on a book tour with
"Memory Man" the first time, I
asked people "Raise your hand
if you think it would be really cool
to never be able to
forget anything."
A lot of people raised their hand.
Okay, "Raise your hand
if you have something
in your life you'd rather forget."
Everybody raised their hand,
and those who didn't were lying
to themselves by the way.
So that's the albatross
around Amos's neck.
That's what makes him human.
That's what makes us sort of root
and care for him, because we know
that he's in the same body, but he's
not the same person he used to be.
Can you imagine that, that you were;
you're a totally different
person now
because something happened here
changed your personality instead
of being outgoing and you
know friendly and gregarious,
and you can't relate to people?
You can't understand
the social cues anymore,
you're on a different spectrum
even though you're in the same body
and you know you're never going
to be who that person used to be.
So, I thought that would be
a unique way to sort of try
to present this character.
It allowed me over many
books, to sort of deepen
and enrich and change who he is.
So, book to book, day-to-day his
brain may rewire itself again.
You never know and he might
become something else.
So, when I write I try to write
about things that interest me.
The old adage is write
what you know.
I would modify that and say, write
what you would like to know about
and then go and find out
about stuff and feel if;
find out if your passion
about something
that will keep the fires burning for
whatever length of time it takes you
to write what you want to write.
You know, what you don't want to
do is halfway through a book run
out of gas because you
figured out, oh you know,
I'm not really interested in this.
I was trying to write the
other, the next Jurassic Park.
You know? When Jurassic Park first
came out, I can guarantee you
that every book proposal and every
screenplay proposal, you know,
had something to do with Jurassic
Park even it was a romantic comedy,
you were going to have
a T-rex in it.
You know, they're going
to be kissing,
it's going to be very romantic
and the T-rex is going to come in
and kill one of them, you know?
Or when the Da Vinci Code
came out everybody was trying
to write the next code book,
because what are they doing?
They were chasing a trend and most
of them didn't finish the book
because they weren't really
interested in dinosaurs or code.
They just thought, oh this
is the next hot trend.
What you need to find is
something you really care about
and guess what the passion
all of a sudden will start
to infect the sentences
and the paragraphs
and the chapters and
the storytelling.
It will come through.
I will make it all better
and all stronger and all
of a sudden what you're
writing it sort of gets lifted
out of the sludge piles, it sits
on an editor's desk in New York.
The book I just finished
and it will be
out in November, it's
called "End Game."
It's Will Robie and Jessica Reel my
two assassins back and it takes them
to an interesting place, the United
States that will be out in November.
They're filming "The Christmas
Train" movie right now in Vancouver.
So they're going to replicate
Christmas in Canada in August.
They've got the snowmaking
machines fired up and ready to go.
It's interesting, I
read a story recently
that said the Hallmark ratings, this
is a Hallmark movie so it will be
on Thanksgiving weekend, Hallmark
ratings are through the roof
like tripled what they were ever
since January [brief laughter].
Pregnant pause there and;
and the article talked
about people are watching
Hallmark because they just want
to feel good again and happy and
all that, so it's a good time
if you're Hallmark and Hallmark
is very happy about that too.
So, it will be; they've been
sending me the dailies every day.
It used to be when you shot on
film you'd have to wait a longtime
to get dailies, so now it's all
video and they just email it to me
and I get to watch what's going on.
They got a great cast and it
looks like it will be pretty good.
The John Puller, I just
signed a deal with Sony TV
to option John Puller
for a television series
for Network Television, so
they're working on that too.
When I was 7 or 8 years
old, I was one of those kids
that never shut up,
you know, I just,
and I just couldn't stop talking.
I would either be arguing with
people or making up tall tales
to get myself out of trouble with
parents, assorted school officials,
people like that, truancy officers.
And when I was around 8,
my mom bought me a journal,
a blank page journal and gave it
to me and said, "You know son,
some of these stories you've been
writing are or talking about,
why don't you try writing them down?
Why don't you try to do that?"
So, I said, "Okay."
I love to read.
I'm a writer today because
I was a reader as a kid.
I love books.
So, my pen hit the paper
and all of a sudden it was
like oh my god this a epiphany.
I can create a story on paper
that other people could read.
I can do for other people what
writers I love have done for me.
You know? They can enthrall me.
Allow me to lost in a world, they
created a world that didn't exist
until they thought of it.
How powerful is that?
So, I put pen to paper and
never really looked back.
I just started to write
and haven't stopped since.
And I went back to my mom
later and I said, "My god mom.
Thank you so much.
What a gift you gave me."
And she said, "Honey I'm so
glad it's worked out for you,
but quite frankly I just wanted
to shut you the hell up."
She said, "I'm your mom.
I will always love you, but even
moms need a little peace and quiet."
I totally get that mom.
Thank you.
Over the years you collect quite
a bit of experiences and stories
and stuff and I wrote a book years
ago called, "The Winner" and in
that book, it was 1998 I think, my
villain figured out a full-proof way
to fix the United States
National Lottery,
such that he could
actually pick the winners.
He didn't do it with a conspiracy.
He didn't do it with
an inside of knowledge,
he did it based on science.
And science in interesting because
unlike anything sort of touched
by human hand, which can fail,
science if you take A and you add B
to it you get C as a result not
60% of the time or 90% of the time,
you get it a 100% of the time.
It's full-proof.
That's what interesting
and so cool about science.
Well after the book came out it very
popular and maybe two years went by.
And I got a call from a
reporter from la Repubblica
which is the largest
daily newspaper in Rome.
And he said, "Mr. Baldacci
I don't know
if you've been following the
Italian lottery scandal."
I said, "Why no.
I must have missed that.
Was it on NPR?"
And he said, "Well, someone
apparently figured out how
to fix the Italian National Lottery
and they used a method very similar
to the one that you wrote
about in The Winner.
Would you like to commit
on that sir?"
I said well, "First
of all that's bad.
That's very bad.
That's a felony.
I would never encourage
anyone to fix the lottery."
And second point, "That's like the
coolest frigging thing anybody's
every told me in my whole life."
But still don't try
to do it, you know.
But if you do it don't tell anybody,
because you know, it's just bad.
That's coconspirators;
if you're going
to commit a conspiracy even though I
know a conspiracy is sort of defined
as more than one person,
don't tell anybody.
You know, it's always
the coconspirators
that take you down, you know?
We're going to be finding
out about that soon.
Anyway.
[ Laughter/Applause ]
My wife, she went to my
talk today on the Teen Stage
so she sent me a text with advice on
things that I should avoid saying.
First of all, she said "For
next talk more appropriate
to talk politics, not with
kids, but not more or too much.
With questions, keep them shorter.
So many people want to ask,
but can't because you're
answers are always far too long."
I'll just stop there.
Anyway, I did mention the
strong independent women, right?
And that's, that's her.
Now, I'm Italian-American
second generation.
My father was first born
in the United States
and his grandfather immigrated
to the United States around turn
of the last century, and he was born
in a little village called Barga,
Italy which is about an hour
north of Pisa in Tuscany.
And my father has always
tried to go to Barga to see
where his father was born.
The closest he made it was Egypt
when he was in World War II.
But the Unites States Navy wouldn't
let him go any farther than that,
so he never made it back to Italy.
So, the year that my dad
unfortunately passed away,
we had made plans to go Barga and I
wanted to go there both for myself
and bring my family so I could
come back and tell my dad.
Unfortunately, I never
got a chance to do that.
But before we went to Barga, I got
an email from the mayor of Barga
and he said, "I read
it in a travel magazine
that you were spending
your holiday in Italy."
Which is kind of creepy right?
And he said, "I would love for
you to come to Barga and I'd love
to take you to lunch and you
can see the city and town
where your grandfather was born."
And I wrote back and
said, "This is fantastic.
I was going to bring
my family anyways."
So we set a date, we flew
over, place where we staying
and then the time came
for us to go to Barga.
We were there, we were
traveling with two other families
and our kids were younger back
then, so we loaded into two cars.
If you've ever driven in
Italy, unless you're like one
of the autobahn, autostradale
places, you can't get anywhere fast.
You probably can't
get anywhere at all.
I mean it's just a lot
of back roads and stuff,
and even though we had a rental
car that we paid for, you know,
like the Hertz NeverLost?
They have the same system in
Italy; slightly different name.
It's called Hertz AwaysLost.
I have yet to drive overseas where
the GPS did not breakdown exactly
when I needed it to work.
So, about 30 minutes outside of
Barga our GPS went on holiday.
And I'm a very punctual person.
I was a trial lawyer for 10 years
and you learn not to be late,
because judges don't like that and
we were already late to this lunch.
So my wife is trying to
navigate using paper maps
and we're driving along and finally
I just stopped at his crossroads;
this intersection that looked
like there was something there
and I said, "Do you
think this is it?
Do you think this is Barga?"
And so she looked out the
window and said, "Well,
considering that there's a 12-foot
tall poster of you on the wall
over there [brief laughter] it's
a pretty good bet we're in Barga."
And then we notice al the traffic
and policemen directing traffic
and I was like "What is going on?"
So, I rolled down the window,
I got the attention of one
of the police officers,
in broken Italian
and his broken English
I asked him, I said "So,
you know what's going on?"
He says, "Oh, it's David
Baldacci Day in Barga.
Park over there."
[ Laughter ]
So, I slowly rolled the window
back and up and I looked
over at my strong, independent
wife and she was looking
at me just incredulous, she said
"David Baldacci Day are
you frigging kidding me?"
And I said, "Honey I had no idea."
And she was like, "Liar!
Look how we're dressed."
And it was August.
Were in shorts and, you know,
I mean we were not dressed up.
So we got out and Barga
like Lucca is a walled city.
So, the gates of the city open
and out marches the mayor.
He's draped in the American
and the Italian flags.
The American flag is
flying over the city
for the first time
since World War II.
Behind the mayor is a marching band.
I swear to god, a marching band.
Behind him where these
videographers and journalists
and behind them were apparently
everybody who lives in Barga.
So, the greeted me and like you know
lots of hugs, lots of kisses, blah,
blah, blah and so they
escorted me in and we went
on a tour of the whole city.
I visited everything, you know,
from the Duomo to the City Hall
to the Courthouse whatever,
and I did a book signing
at the local bookstore and
then we had a fabulous lunch.
It was me, my family and friends,
the mayor, 1100 new friends
and time goes on, you know,
and we had a long drive back.
We were staying a villa
on the side of the hill
with a one lane road going
up, switchbacks all the way.
I mean if you meet
another car going there,
that's why in Italy all the side
view mirrors are all beat to crap,
because as you're going along if
you're on the side with no guardrail
and a 2000 foot drop, you're
like hugging and I don't care
if you hit my car,
I'm not going over.
So, we wanted to get back to
our villa before nightfall.
I did not want to drive
up there at night.
I just didn't.
And so, Michelle my wife, Michelle
said "You know, this has been great.
It's getting late.
Go tell the mayor thanks,
we're out of here."
So, I went over to the mayor and I
said, "Well this has been fantastic.
I got to see where my grandfather
was born and walk the streets
that he walked, but we have to."
And then he goes, "And now, it
is time to give your grand speech
in the center courtyard
of the city."
I was like, "Okay."
So, we marched to the grand
center courtyard of the city
which is lovely, and the
band does one more song
and then they stop playing
and the mayor gets up
and they have two translators
because I don't speak
Italian well enough
to give a grand speech
in the language.
And the mayor gets up and
starts giving us presents.
You know, he gave me a
lifetime supply of olive oil.
That was a lot of fun getting
back on the plane; an oil painting
by a local Barga artist; a
genealogical chart framed
that they had put together
from their archives
from the Baldacci family in
Barga from the 11th century
to my grandfather's generation.
So I saw siblings of my grandfather
I never even knew existed,
because they didn't immigrate
to the United States.
I never even heard of these people.
My grandfather dies unfortunately
long before I was even born.
I never even met him.
He moved to Richmond, Virginia
after coming immigrating
through Ellis Island in New
York, met my grandmother
at a boarding house that
her mother ran in Richmond.
My grandfather's name was
Amedeo Batorio Giovanni Baldacci
[assumed spelling].
Having grown in the
South, I can tell you
that southern tongues do
not wrap themselves easily
around foreign sounding
names like that.
So, instead of calling him
Amedeo Batorio Giovanni everybody
in Richmond called
my grandfather Mike.
[ Laughter ]
So, we got the genealogical chart
and then they gave me a book
and the book was came from the
town archive it was journal
that my ancestor Peatre Baldacci
[assumed spelling] started writing
in in the 1630s.
And because paper was scarce
back then if you passed away
and there was paper left, it was
just handed to the next generation.
So, the last entry in that
journal is from the 1880s.
It covers almost 250
years of my family.
That was a pretty special thing.
So that was with me and
then the mayor says,
"Okay the Baldacci
bambinos, venga" my kids.
"Come on up."
So back then my daughter
was 14-15; my son was 12.
So teenage girl.
So the seas of people part and
my daughter is having to walk
up between this gauntlet of people
all eye on her and she's walking up,
she's not looking at the mayor.
She's not looking at
anybody other than me.
And she's looking at me and all
you dads out there with daughters,
she's looking at me with a look
that says, you've ruined my life.
And I'm so going to get you.
Now, to complete the Mars/Venus
story, here is my 12-year-old son
and it's turn to come
up, here's what he does.
[ Laughter ]
The brain wiring I'm sticking to it.
I mean, grew up in the same house,
same set of rules,
totally different kids.
My gosh. So then I
gave my grand speech.
Obviously I had nothing prepared.
But I said, "You know, even though
it's August if feels like Christmas.
Because this outpouring of family,
friendship and just my own history
that I didn't know existed
until I arrived here,
it's been so overwhelming
and probably one
of the greatest gifts
I've ever received."
And after my speech was
done and we were leaving,
one of the people we had traveled
there with said, "David you have
to come over and meet
these gentlemen."
There were 4 very elderly men on
this bench and they all had canes
and felt caps and they were all
holding one copy of one of my books.
And I went over to my friend
and said, "Oh who are they?"
And I think the youngest
was in his middle 80s,
the oldest was close to 100.
And I asked our friend,
"Who are they?"
And he said, "They're
all Baldacci's.
They all came from other
countries today to meet you."
So these 4 elderly men stood
up, took their caps off
and bowed in respect to me.
And all being Italians, we
just started sobbing; sobbing
and hugging, hugging and sobbing.
But it really was one of the most
perfect days of my life, you know,
and we've never have had the
opportunity to go over there
if hadn't been a writer and been
interested in my family history,
but it was just an amazing day.
And I memorialized that story
that I just told you, all true,
in a travel story that I wrote for
"Lonely Planet" their travel guide.
They asked a bunch
of writers to write
about your favorite travel
story and they called me up
and said, "Do you have one?"
And I said, "Yeah.
I think I have a favorite
travel story."
So the title of the
story is entitled,
"Coming Home" even
though I had never been
to Barga before in my whole life.
It really felt like
I was coming home.
A couple more stories
and I'll take questions.
I do a lot of research for my books.
Hopefully if you've
read them you can tell.
The most important
thing about research
for a novel is to leave
most of it out.
You know, you could spend months
and months and months for a line
of dialogue, a few sentences
here or there, description
but you're not writing a
textbook and you have to fight
against the compulsion to cram
all your research in there,
because you're so proud
of what you did
and you don't want
to waste it, right?
If you try to do that,
most authors instead
of integrating it throughout
they just get oh I know
and they just stick in one spot.
And I call those books flip books.
We've all read them.
And a flip book is a writer has done
that and you're reading as a reader
and you're enjoying
the story and all
of a sudden you're like "Oh my god.
What's this?"
Flip, flip, flip, flip,
flip, flip, flip, flip, flip,
flip past all the research
that they crammed in there
because it really has nothing to do
with propelling the story forward
and then you get back to the
story and you're enjoying it.
So, you got to leave
most of the research out.
But I still do a lot of
research, one, because I enjoy it.
I like learning about
things, you know,
I like meeting fascinating people.
I just love that.
But research can get you into
an enormous amount of trouble.
And it happened to me
on one faithful day.
I was leaving not too far from
here, I was at Union Station.
I was on an Amtrak Acela train, this
other train going up to New York
and I'm sitting at table that
I'm sharing with two other guys;
I don't know them, you
know, you just share tables.
And I assumed they were businessmen,
because they were in suits
and they had Blackberries and cell
phones and Smartphones and laptops,
a miniature satellite
towers you know?
These guys were like doing
deals and it was cool and I was
on my cellphone calling a friend
of mine who was a medical examiner
in the Bronx Medical Examiner's
Office in New York and all I wanted
to do was setup an appointment,
so when I got to New York
I could meet with her.
She was sort of a recognized expert
on this field of forensic science.
I needed to know more about to
write a book called "Split Second."
It was the first novel in
the King and Maxwell series;
just wanted to set
an appointment up.
I like to do my interviews
face-to-face.
Unfortunately, she told
that she was leaving
to go overseas on special
assignment.
She was going to be leaving to go to
JFK before I even got to New York.
She was helping in a homicide
investigation overseas as part
of an effort with the
State Department.
She had the special
set of forensic skills.
She was going to be
gone for about 3 weeks.
It was a sort of a
confidential investigation.
No communication was going
to be allowed stateside
while they were there,
so I could either ask the questions
now or wait until she got back.
I really didn't want to wait,
so I said "Look I don't normally
like to do it this way,
so let's just do it."
So, I had my questions
and I said, "Okay,
doc here's basically how
I want to murder the guy."
[ Laughter ]
I know. I know.
So I went through my really
elaborate poisoning technique
that I had given a
lot of thought to.
And I said, "Look doc you have
to understand you know I need
to make sure that the
police when they come
to investigate this homicide they
won't even know this person's
been murdered."
And she said, "David, what you
just described really is the
perfect crime.
You know, the police
investigation will not you know show
that this was a murder."
I said, "Okay, but there's going to
be a postmortem done on the body.
I need to be able to
fool a medical examiner.
They won't know the
person's been murdered."
She said, "David, trust me.
I've often thought about
murdering people [brief laughter].
If you do it the way
you described to me,
there's no postmortem
protocols that I know
of that would detect this
person has been murdered."
So, I asked a few more questions
and I ended by saying "I got
to tell you doc, if I ever need to
kill anybody else, I'm calling you."
So, I clicked off,
put my phone down,
I finished writing my
notes, and I looked up.
The guy over here has spilled his
coffee from his neck to his crotch.
He was like one big brown stain
and incredibly pissed off.
I will never forget the guy
right across from me for the rest
of my life I'll never;
he never said a word.
This is what he was doing.
[ Laughter ]
And over his shoulder here
come the Amtrak police.
No lie. Amtrak has
its own police force.
I did not make it to
New York that day.
I was detained as a person of
interest by the Amtrak police
who apparently don't
read a whole lot.
[ Laughter ]
So, if you read "Split
Second" you'll see
in the acknowledgement section
which is in the back of the book,
this is the place where
authors thank people
who help them with the book.
The very last acknowledgement in
"Split Second" reads something
like this; to any all passengers
on the Amtrak Acela train
who might have overheard
me discussing
with an expert poisoning techniques
for purposes of researching
and writing a novel that were
probably scared out of their wits
at my seemingly diabolical
intent, I apologize.
I thought it was actually
pretty fair of the judge
to let me do it that way.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, the last story is,
again, completely true.
The other question
I get from people is
"Well you're a famous writer
you must get recognized
in public all the time."
Almost never.
It's we're not like real
celebrities,, you know,
in America writers
are not celebrities.
We're not like musicians or actors
or athletes, it just doesn't happen,
which is not a bad thing.
I wouldn't want to walk out
of my house and get mobbed,
it's just crazy but even
when you are recognized
in public it's not the ego stroke
that you think it might
otherwise be.
So, my wife and I were having lunch,
so I don't even remember
which city we were in.
We were in a booth having a nice
lunch and, you know, you look up
and I was looking around the
restaurant and over on this side far
across the restaurant
there was a man and a woman
at a table eating lunch, and the
woman was like laser locked on me.
I looked over and it's
like my god you know.
She's like staring a hole right
through me and I waited a minute
and I thought well I must have
totally misinterpreted that.
So, I you know, I kind of gradually
looked over again, laser lock.
You know, it was like I had
a sniper dot on my forehead.
It was just freaky.
So, I just stopped looking
and I'm just eating my lunch,
eating my lunch and a few minutes go
by and then I sense a presence next
to me and I thought
it was our waitress
and I looked up, it's the woman.
And she pushes me over in the
booth and sits down next to me.
And then she looks at me and says,
"You are who I think
you are aren't you?"
Any English teachers want to
try diagram that sentence?
It's actually got a
lot going on, you know.
And I didn't know who she was.
I didn't know if she was psychotic.
I didn't know if she had a gun, you
know, I was trying to eat my lunch.
And I said, "Well" I'm
trying to keep it calm.
"A-- do you read a lot of fiction?"
She said, "Oh yes I do."
I said, "Well um than I guess
I am who you think I am."
And then she just lost it
and she said, "Oh my god,
never in my wildest dreams did
I think I would ever have the
opportunity to meet you.
This is so mindboggling, I can't
even process what's happening.
This is the most magical
moment of my entire life."
And she turns and screams
across the restaurant
to I guess her husband,
"I was right Joe!
It is John Grisham!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yep.
Now, I've known John a
longtime and great guy.
You know, every time I've asked to
help out with a charitable event
or something he always steps up.
He's just a wonderful guy.
That moment in my life I really
wasn't feeling the love for John.
You know, my poor wife.
She blew ice tea out of her nose.
Literally.
And said very politely
to the woman, you know,
she goes "That's the right genre,
but you got the wrong author."
And the woman did look mortified and
she looked at me again and she said,
"Oh my god are you Baldacci?"
[ Laughter ]
I really can't make this up folks.
I really can't.
And I said, "Yeah I am."
So, obviously terribly she grinned
that I was not messier Grisham.
She turns and screams across
the frigging restaurant again,
"You were right Joe,
it is the Italian."
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Anybody have any questions?
Yes.
>> Hi, you're a great storyteller
even the stories tonight.
So, with legal thrillers I've
been reading a lot of them.
I'm writing one actually.
>> David Baldacci: Right.
>> And a lot of them
have a lot of bodies.
Can you write a legal thriller
that doesn't have a lot
of people dying all over the place?
>> David Baldacci: A lot of bodies?
>> Yeah.
>> David Baldacci:
All over the place?
Yes. I have written thrillers that
don't have a lot of bodies all
over the place and quite frankly
you know, the a lot of the violence
and graphic and gore and stuff, I
leave to the people's imagination.
I don't really need to write all
of that, only if it's important
to move the story along; only
because it's a red herring;
only because it's a clue later on.
I find that it dilutes the power
of what you're trying to do.
Some of the best crime novels
out there have only
involved one killing.
It makes, you know,
solving that crime paramount
and also makes the life
of that person really,
really incredibly valuable
and important and significant.
If you have somebody who's,
look if you have a serial killer
and they're killing multiple
people and that's important
for the story, than absolutely.
But, you know, to kill 30
or 40 or 50 people just
because you think the
body count is going
to help book sales, probably not.
It's got to be; everything has
to really be faithful and true
and make sense for the
story you're trying to tell.
So, the body count should
not be a body count just
to [inaudible] you know bodies.
It's got to be integral to the
part and you have to be respect
and have the integrity of the story.
>> Hi. I'm sure you've been
asked this all the time,
I'll just ask it again.
Talk a little bit about the
writing process for you.
Do you block off an entire
day, go out for lunch, write,
than go out for dinner or do
you try to just put as much
as you can intensively in that day?
And also, do you get together with
some of your writing colleagues
and trade craft or
challenges and share moments
that worked and moments that didn't?
>> David Baldacci: Okay, the writing
process and what is my typical day
like and do I hangout
with John Grisham?
Anyway.
>> Right.
>> David Baldacci: My days are
typical for being atypical.
You know, I know a lot of writers
will have a, you know, 4-page a day,
5-page a day, 2000 words a day;
that's never worked for me.
One, because I may not have 2000
words that I'm going to be able
to write that day, or I may have
10,000 and why should I stop?
I tend to write until the tank is
empty and however many words it ends
up or pages it doesn't
matter to me so long as I get
out that day what I want to get out.
Some days I don't write anything.
Some days it's just not
there, it's not crystalized.
I haven't thought it through enough.
I don't outline everything.
You know, I've written
over 40 books.
I've never known the ending
of any of my books until I,
you know, get to the end.
When I sit down to start a book, I
have no idea how it's going to end.
You know, I work my way there.
I use many, many outlines.
You know, miniature
outlines when I need to,
but I really like immerse
myself in the story
and therefore I don't really feel
like I need to map everything out.
Plus, it could work really
well when you write an outline.
It's almost like practicing you know
you're a practice player in the NFL
and then game day comes and you're
actually playing for real with,
you know, the best in the NFL.
It's different.
So, it might have sounded brilliant
in the outline and then you sit
down to write an implemented
outline on a printed page,
and all of a sudden you realize
this doesn't work at all.
You know, because I
had the note over here,
it said "Come up with
something brilliant",
it's just not working, you know?
The outline says, "brilliant."
I can't make it, you
know, what's brilliant?
You have to be true to the story.
And like in Amos Decker the
very first name was Decker
or "Memory Man."
I didn't even know the guy.
So how could I write an
outline of the entire book
when I had never even spent
time on a page with him?
I had to get a feel for him, his
voice, how he walked, you know,
how he dealt with people, what
his thought process were like.
In order to do that, you
got to write the stuff
and it may not work the first time,
or the second, or the tenth time.
So for me, every day is different
which I think is a good thing.
I don't want to drop into a routine
because I think my writing
will become routine, you know,
and instead of trying to
treat every novel I write
as the very first novel that I have
written, scared you know to death
that I can't do it again,
not sure of what I'm doing.
I always thought that fear
gave me an edge to explore
and to exploit things that if
I were in a routine and I felt
like I had a template that I felt
like I knew what I was doing,
all of sudden as Truman
Capote once said,
"That's now writing, that's typing."
>> What's the hardest character
that you've ever written
and why were they hard to write?
>> David Baldacci: The hardest
characters that I've ever written
and why were they hard to write?
I have a series that I've
written a number of books about
and I probably get this
more than anything else,
"When is the Camel Club
going to come back?
When is the Camel Club
going to come back?"
[Applause] I know, I know.
So, these were you know a handful
of distinctly different characters,
you know, none of them were anything
that I had remotely
anything in common with.
They were older than I was
and I really wasn't sure what I
wanted them to be or to represent,
but I knew that I wanted them
to have sort of this anchor
in Oliver Stone, not the film
director, the other Oliver Stone.
And then this sort of
entourage, this ensemble cast
of characters around them.
It took me a longtime to really
craft each of those characters
in a way that make them
individualistic and memorable.
You know, the hardest
thing about ensemble casts,
is that some of them start
to blur together, you know,
and they don't have
their distinct identity.
So, the Camel Club probably,
but once I got going with them,
subsequent books were a lot easier,
but that first one was
really, really hard.
Yes, ma'am.
>> First I want to
say thank you so much
for being here for all of us today.
You're very first book
that you wrote, what,
I mean you said you
were an attorney.
What propelled you into writing?
What was that like when you
first sat down to write it?
And how did you do your
character development?
>> David Baldacci: What propelled me
to write my first novel and you know
when I sat down to write it with
the character development and?
I started out writing short stories
when I was in high school, college,
law school and practicing law.
I moved onto screenplay writing.
A friend of mine went to
L.A. to break into film.
He's a producer, he
brought a script back.
I've never read a script in my life.
I read it and I though this is an
interesting way to tell a story.
It's not going end up on a
printed page; it's going to be
on a wall with you know sound.
So, over the course of 4 or 5 years
while I was practicing law I wrote 5
original screenplays.
I got an agent in L.A.
based on that.
I came really close; in 1991 I wrote
a script called "Reverse Order."
It was "Die Hard" in
the White House.
You probably saw it on film like 14
years later written by somebody else
and that I though was
going to be my big break.
My agent said everybody
loves the script.
Warner Brothers is
mad over the script;
Paramount Pictures it's going to
be bidding war, blah, blah, blah,
ended up not selling at all.
You know, all of the studios
for whatever reason
found a problem with it.
I found in Hollywood
over these years,
I worked on many film projects,
movies and television that it's far;
nobody out in Hollywood
ever got fired
for saying no to a
project, you know.
So, that's when I started
thinking about a novel.
And my law office was very near
the White House and I would go out
and you know walk around.
I'd see the secret service,
occasionally see the
presidential motorcade.
And I thought you know, I'm going
to write a book that's going
to flip all the stereotypes.
I'm going to make the good people
bad and the bad people good,
so I wrote a story about the
president, a twist with a mistress,
a cover-up, the secret service
was part of the cover-up
and a burglar this bad guy,
had the highest morals
of anyone in the story.
So, I spent 3 years of my
life writing that novel.
No, you know, no thought
that anybody was actually
going to buy it.
I just thought it was a cool story.
So, I just wrote every
day a little bit.
I'd get home from work, write
in the middle of the night.
I just wrote a little bit every day
for 3 years and it was finally done.
And some of it, there was a young
lawyer in the book "Jack Graham"
and that was somewhat based on me
because I was a young lawyer
back then, but it was sort
of dynamics of Washington, you know?
Because I had worked a lot you
know with you know organizations
in D.C. I thought I knew
the city pretty well,
so a lot of it was just
experiences that I had
and just using my imagination
to fill-in everything else.
It was so funny after the; the book
was published; I wrote the book
in like 1993 it was done.
It was published in 1996.
So, in 19, probably 1999 I got
a; I get a lot of fan letters.
Back then it was real
fan letters, tons.
Now it's all emails, but a lady
wrote me, she was very upset.
She said, "I read Absolute Power."
I can't believe you took a
national tragedy and turned it
into a bestselling novel.
And she was referring to the
Clinton/Monica Lewinsky stuff.
And I wrote her back and I was like
"Oh, you know, just to let you know
if you see the copyright
page where it says
where the book was published, the
book was published in 1996, January,
2-and-a-half years before anyone
ever heard of Monica Lewinsky.
And I thought, you know,
she just made a mistake.
That's no problem and that
would be the end of it.
Like in 2 days later I get
a letter back from her.
It was just one line that
said, "That proves nothing!"
[ Laughter ]
I've still got that letter.
And it just goes to show, you know,
once people believe
something it's really hard.
Yes, ma'am.
>> Two or 3 years ago I read a
biography of Louisa May Alcott
and one of the things
that is memorable
for me was how rapidly
she wrote "Little Women."
I think I read she wrote
it in 3 or 4 weeks,
something like that very brief.
So, 2 questions in that regard.
Which book did you write most
rapidly, and a 150 years from now,
which of your books will people
still be giving to one another
and reading if you had to pick one?
>> David Baldacci: What
was the second one again?
>> A 150 years from now, like
Little Women is still read;
which of your books 150 years from
now do you think will still be read?
>> David Baldacci: Okay.
>> And then one final follow-up
question since you're local
and I think from Fairfax
County, can you tell a little bit
about your foundation and how you're
involved with the local youth?
>> David Baldacci: Absolutely, yep.
So, remind me the first
question was?
>> Which of your books did
you write most rapidly?
>> David Baldacci: Right, okay.
>> Any in 3 weeks?
>> David Baldacci: The book
that I wrote the fastest
was not a thriller.
It was called, "One Summer."
And it was a sort of
a family tragedy.
And the only reason that
book was written was
because my son was receiving
Confirmation in the Catholic Church
and my wife told me to go to
the church early to save seats,
because it was going to
fill up and we had family
and friends flying
in from out of town.
So I went there to save seats.
And it was just me and the
priest who I knew very well,
so we were just sitting there,
but I had like 2 hours to kill
and my dad had just passed
away, my mom was very ill,
my son was receiving, my last child
was receiving his last major step
in the Catholic Church.
The next after Confirmation
is last rights basically.
So it was almost like, you
know, I felt myself coming
up to the turnstile too, you know?
And the years were going on,
and while I was sitting
there 2 hours the story
for "One Summer" just unspooled
in my head totally from A to Z.
That almost never happens.
So, I went back and I wrote it.
I probably wrote that book in maybe
2 months, while I was writing,
you know, my other
thrillers as well.
And nobody knew I was writing it.
When I sent it up to my agent he was
astounded and, but it was a story
that resonated deeply with me
and the premise is a
very simple premise.
It's the family, they have3 kids.
The dad is terminally ill
with an incurable disease.
He's in Hospice, Home Hospice
and he's preparing himself
and his family for he won't
be there and the mom is going
to be the surviving parent and the
family is trying to deal with that.
And because of sort of a
twist of fate, the father ends
up being the surviving parent
and he has to deal with that.
I don't know why it hit me
so completely, but it did.
It's just one of those
things that happens in life.
The book that I will; that
people will be reading
about of mine a 150 years from
now, I'll reserve the right to say
that it might be one that
I haven't written yet.
I wrote a book years ago it was made
into a film called "Wish You Well."
And that was a film very; a book
very near and dear to my heart
and it was totally different, it
was like my, if I'm going to have a
"To Kill a Mocking Bird"
experience it would that.
I'm very much into
intimately involved
with my own family's history in
Southwest Virginia on top of a ridge
in one of the most isolated
parts of the United States.
I remember, I still remember
to this day a 2004 article
in the Washington Post in 2004,
they finally pulled running water
and electricity up to
Ramsey's Ridge in 2004.
Up until that time, it was
all well water and coal fire
or oil lanterns if
you can imagine that.
It's always been a
huge part of my life.
If you think of the name
like Baldacci, you know,
I definitely have that
ethnicity as well.
My mother's maiden name was Rose.
So they had been in Virginia in
the south for a long, longtime.
So it was really sort of a
mash of 2 cultures for me.
And growing up in Richmond with a
name that no one could pronounce,
you know, I ended up answering
mostly to David Baldwin.
So, I felt you know sort of
like an outsider as well.
I love, I'm sort of
the anti-narcissist.
I know I'm up here
speaking before all of you,
but I'm the anti-narcissist: I would
much rather be out there looking
and listening in on all of you.
That's what I would
much rather be doing.
The Wish You Well Foundation my
wife and I started it 16 years ago.
We fund literacy programs
across the United States.
The ability to read is the most
important tool you'll ever have
in your life, because it
allows you to unleash this.
You know, the verbs to read
and to think are synonymous.
You can't do one without the other.
It's almost impossible.
And today, you see a
very divided country.
I went to UVA Law School.
I lived in Charlottesville
for 3 years.
I saw what happened there.
I saw some of the responses
of people
that should know better
of what happened there.
Ignorance and intolerance are
like parentheses or comas,
you always find them together.
You never find one
without the other.
The only way to defeat
ignorance is through education
and reading is the mainstay
of education, and you get rid
of ignorance than tolerance
will fall by the wayside.
If you don't, it never will.
So, for us, literacy is
the most important tool
and we have funded programs
virtually in all 50 states
and counting, millions of dollars
to the Wish You Well Foundation.
We also have a book collection
program called Feeding Body and Mind
when I do local book events;
we send these big boxes.
We partnered with Feeding
America which is all
of the nation's foodbanks.
People come and donate books and we
ship those books to foodbanks all
over the country and over the
last 6 or 7 years we've shipped
over 2 million books to foodbanks.
People need food to survive,
but alone it can't break them
out that cycle of poverty.
Illiteracy and poverty
go hand-in-hand.
It's also most like parentheses;
most people seeking food
systems have low literacy skills,
low job skills, that's why
they are not self-sustaining.
Breaking them out of
that cycle of poverty,
putting books in their hands
and the hands of their kids,
I have never seen a bad result
from a book being at home.
I have seen many bad results
from no books being at home.
In the United States of America,
that should never be
happening today.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. Well, my the early one
she asked one of my questions
and you answered another one of
my questions, but I still I would
like to take this opportunity
to give some comments.
First of all, I thank you
for being here and would
like to ask the Library
of Congress not
to answer your call
to stop inviting you.
[ Applause ]
>> David Baldacci: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> And obviously you wear so many
extraordinary hats; writer, lawyer,
storytelling, storyteller,
and my 12-year-old son
the earlier comments.
You look like a very much
politician and actor.
>> David Baldacci: Yeah.
>> But I'm most impressed
and interested
in your role as a humanitarian.
So, I wanted to say my questions as
a proof that I came with questions.
That's how and why
you coined your name
of your foundation We Wish You Well?
And what's the most that you're
proudest accomplishment so far?
But, I think you already answered.
Thank you.
>> David Baldacci: Okay.
Great question.
You know, my wife and I
thought long and hard about it.
The novel "Wish You Well"
came before the foundation,
but not that long before it.
And we sat and talked about it
and we came to the conclusion
that the best way we could
wish someone well was
to help them to learn to read.
And once you've had
that skill, I mean,
everybody in this room
you're all readers,
you all love books
that's why you're here.
When I'm out talking about it
doing fundraisers and trying
to impress upon people, in an
area like this in Washington,
D.C. where everybody has 3 PhDs, you
know, it's hard for them to fathom
that there are, you know,
over a 100 million Americans
who lack basic literacy
skills, so wishing someone well
in our mind means helping
them to learn how to read.
If they can have that one skill
they can rise to opportunities
to the occasion,
to self-empowerment,
and self-sustaining.
You know, I think one of the
best things that we've done,
we do a lot of programs
with prison populations.
Recidivism rates are
through the roof.
This country went through, you know,
probably a 15 to 20 year period
where they really emphasized
rehabilitation
and then you know the hammer came
down and it was like, you know,
you're getting locked up and
you're going to be treated
like you're bad people and then
they wonder why when they come out,
one they commit crimes again
or two they go right back in.
So, we do a lot of program;
we fund a lot of programs
with prison populations
where they have peer review
where fellow prisoners are taught to
be tutors of their fellow prisoners.
They have credibility,
people can relate to them.
They understand, they also see
that person as a role model.
So, we funded a lot of programs
across a number of states that deal
with that very issue, because
that is a neglected population.
And I have to say that, the Wish You
Well's mission statement has grown
over the years.
We call ourselves a
family foundation,
but we really we're mostly
focused on adult illiteracy
because there's very little
government funding for that
and it comes mostly
through private foundations.
But we've come to learn that
our mission statement needed
to be broadened to include; kids,
children, and neglected populations
that may not fit precisely with what
we're trying to do, but at the end
of the day it lifts up everyone.
So I think, you know, probably one
of the proudest things we've done is
trying to help neglected populations
that without that support,
will never be able
to find their footing
in mainstream society.
So, by doing that, you know, we
help everybody at the end of the day
and so that's probably you know one
of the proudest accomplishments
we've had.
[Inaudible] thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> David Baldacci: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. You spoke of
your son's Confirmation
so I assume you're Catholic.
I actually go to Catholic
University of America
and I was wondering how much your
fate influences your writing if any,
and if it affects you at any point?
>> David Baldacci: How
much does my faith,
you know, impact on my writing.
I will tell a little secret even
though my grandparents were Catholic
when they were in Italy.
When they came to the United
States they both left the church.
So, David Baldacci in Richmond,
I was raised as a Baptist.
Can you believe that?
But my wife, wife's family is
Catholic and I like to tell people
as a Baptist I over the last 20
years I've attended far more masses
as a Baptist than most Catholics do
in their entire life, every Sunday
and sometimes more than once a week.
But over the years, I have
become a lot more involved
in the Catholic Church
and both of our kids
when through parochial education
and I got a really
great grounding in that.
And I do have to say that
it does impact my writing
in how my characters are built, how
they respond in certain situations,
the sorts of things that they say
and what is meaningful to them.
And I will continue to do that.
I'm not going to get a box,
soapbox and try to pound something.
That doesn't work.
That just turns people off.
If you can say things subtly, lay
it out there and let people arrive
with their own conclusions,
that's far better than trying
to drive a nail through their head,
because it's just going
to work that way.
You know, earlier on in my
career I used to do that
and which is counterproductive
and really interfere with the flow
of the story and it just
wasn't the proper place.
I have other ways where
I can do that.
So I will always, you know,
profoundly impact what
I write about.
We'll take one last question.
>> Thank you.
Amazing. Thank you for being here.
Considering your comments
on politics, you're,
the fact that you're a lawyer,
you live around the D.C. area
and you mentioned politics and
the intrigue that's taking place,
is there sufficient set of
ingredients for you to get inspired
to write something in the
future regarding what's going
on using this as a foundation?
>> David Baldacci: I don't think
I need to repeat that question.
You would not believe, if you go
on my Twitter feed, every day,
you know, I get comments from
like "Baldacci must have plotted
out his next 12 books
based on current events."
You know, or "What happened today
in the New York Times reported,
I think that was in a
Baldacci book 4 years ago."
It can't help but impact what I
write about and it's a balance.
Again, you know, I'm
writing a novel.
But I have to say, as a
novelist I've always felt,
and I feel this strongly, I am only
bound by plausibility, but I am.
[ Laughter ]
And I can't tell you
how liberated I feel.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.